can you do me a favor and put that sword  down  [Music]  [Music]  related to charlemagne  he lied to justin captain  code  justin  you got what can you do me a favor and  put that sword down  get real  fish  die  military style  cut off  scared why are you so upset justin  hey you cut my head  [Music]  [Music]  why are you upset today justin  i'm trying to understand i want to talk  to you i want to get you some help  don't come at me with that shoot  don't come at me with that justin come  on man you don't want to do this run run  run  what do you do  picture to my left too after viewing the  body worn camera footage is a still  photo  from the body worn camera showing mr  charlie lunging towards the officer with  the sword  and again this is a another closer photo  of that officer firing around striking  mr charland  with the suspect within about two to  three yards of our officer